When we experience different emotions, different parts of our body respond
differently. Many of the bodily systems involve the autonomic nervous system,
which includes a sympathetic and parasympathetic nervous systems. As you may
recall from lesson three, the sympathetic nervous system is the arousal system.
It readies the body for action, whereas the parasympathetic nervous system
brings the levels of arousal levels down so we can calm down. Basic survival
and protection experiences activate the sympathetic nervous system to either
fight or flight, meaning flee. Different emotions have their own pattern of
arousal. Anger, for instance, increases heart rate and skin temperature,
whereas sadness decreases both. And fear increases heart rate somewhat and
sweating. And positive emotions generally activate the parasympathetic nervous
system, leading to a sense of calm or relaxation.